listen interestingly enough of course
the popular saying is that there are two
things that you cannot choose in Russia
you're president and your parents but
what is critically important is that
while Russia is not a democracy
elections have been always very
important for the legitimation of
President Putin every elections was
serving to show the people that there is
no alternative to Putin and on this
elections this is not simply is there
going to be a candidate I don't believe
that the elections are going to be
organized if Putin is running that he's
going to lose the elections but for the
first time President Putin is going to
be challenged not so much from those who
said why did you start this stupid War
but also those who are saying why you
are not winning this bloody war
so for the first time the criticism to
Kremlin are coming not simply from the
liberal sources but also from a much
more extreme nationalistic position
saying okay you started but why you're
not winning and this creates a moment of
vulnerability it also creates a moment
of vulnerability because Russian
population was kind of quite ready to
live with the idea of the Special
Operations something like the large
version of Crimea where basically the
Russian army goes succeeds in several
weeks and the people are just going to
cheer it in the way you're cheering as a
football team but now you have a
mobilization and probably you're going
to have a mobileization and probably
they're going to be more than half a
million young men that are going to be
thrown uh to the battlefield and many of
them are going to be killed this is a
different social contract and from this
point of view President Putin is
vulnerable and he should try to find a
way to explain to the Russians why this
war is taking place of course his major
narrative is that he's not fighting
Ukraine he's fighting the west but if
he's fighting the West what is the
Victory and in my view this story to
explain the people what is a victory and
why they should suffer is going to be
very difficult and this is why the
election campaign is a moment of
vulnerability and my feeling is that the
Russian leaders the Russian leader knows
very well this
and when we think about what leaders are
offering their people zelenski
is
popular of course he didn't flee he
stayed he's leading day by day but at
the same time he's Limited in any change
he can offer I'm I'm I assume that it's
going to be very hard for him to say
look we should talk to the Russians when
facing re-election himself totally and
from this point of view it's very
important that for Ukraine first it's
very important to organize the elections
and listen it is not easy you organizing
the elections in a country in which the
majority of the population is not living
in the places in which they have been
living in the day the war started some
have been emigrated are they going to
vote some have been moved because of of
occupation and uh because of the
distractions so first and it's
critically important for Ukraine to show
the infrastructural capacity to organize
the elections and secondly of course
president zielinski is very popular but
president zielinski is very popular
because he's telling his own people I'm
not going to go on any compromise I'm
not ready to do any type of a
territorial concession the moment he
said okay let's see what kind of
concession I can do be sure that they're
going to be another candidate which is
going to run on the elections and saying
no this is not what we have been talking
about you have told to the people that
we are going to liberate all our
territory and this makes me believe that
for the same reasons we discussed about
Russia and Ukraine for both countries
it's going to be very difficult for us
to have any meaningful negotiations in
2023 and secondly there is not good even
possibility for the conflict to freeze
in 2023 because in the elections in 2024
to a great extent that defining what is
possible and what is not possible and of
course what is happening on the ground
is the most important end in the wars
what is deciding decisive is really uh
what the armies are doing but this kind
of a very important constraints mate is
very clear that president zielinski is a
the strong pressure to stay where he is
and to do what he has promised to do and
to be honest this is also true for
President Putin who is insisting we are
winning this is our land and so on and
obviously he's not winning at the moment
but he should try to convince his own
population that he's doing this so I'm
saying this because this type of a
perspective from the elections is not
going to tell us what is going to happen
but probably is going to help us to
understand what is not likely to happen